there is some blowback now and Target's
paying the price here is video from NBC
reporting the target is in a bit of
trouble
a controversy over pride month products
is causing headaches for retail giant
Target it says safety is behind its
decision to Halt some sales Miguel
almaguer explains
or get one of the nation
lers is
products that celebrate pride month off
store shelves citing threats to
employees the company says given these
volatile circumstances we are making
adjustments to our plans including
removing items that have been at the
center of the most significant
confrontational Behavior okay these are
like
naked people on shirts the retailer
removing lgbtq brand at prowlin from
their stores and website whose products
featured satanic themes Target also
reportedly reviewing its adult
collection of Tuck friendly swimsuits
that allows trans people who have not
had gender affirming operations to
conceal their private parts those items
have been at the center of
misinformation the misinformation here
was that kids were being targeted with
this stuff they realize if they can
threaten enough people if they can scare
enough people in real life locations
that maybe support for the lgbtq
community will diminish among
corporations hi impressive carrying
skills right Target is hardly the only
Corporation under attack last month
after a transgender influencer promoted
Bud Light conservative commentators and
some celebrities called for a boycott
sales slumped nearly 30 percent I think
there's this really small group who has
an outsized voice at this moment in time
and it's of hate and it's of hit
discrimination and it's violent tonight
corporations and controversy with pride
month days away again this is about kids
this stuff is always pushed in kids
sections also you might be wondering why
they would have said let's put aside the
lgbtq2 spirit stuff for just a sec let's
just say we're all good with that why do
they have they literally had a satanic
trans person as the lead designer all
this they were putting satanic messages
that you could buy they had little uh
Little Gems and things and things on the
shirts satanic messages for the children
is that a problem like what in God's
name is going on here but of course what
they're doing first off NBC calls it
misinformation you know whatever but
what they're also doing is they're
playing the victim oh we're removing
this stuff because people were trying to
be mean to us they were saying mean
things and threatening our employees
there were no threats this is complete
nonsense what they are threatened by is
that their bottom dollar is being hit
right 10 billion dollar loss of your
stock that might be a reason to change
course and that's also the beauty
when people themselves make choices and
you stop funding the organizations that
are working against your values then
they turn around but they don't want to
say that like oh actually maybe this
wasn't the best idea and we shouldn't be
pushing this tucking nonsense on
children are they oh well it's because
those crazy Ultra Maga people I have no
doubt were actually coming to hurt our
employees just nonsense
[Music]
thank you